if anyone tells you that a certain
person speaks ill of you
do not make excuses about what is said
of you
but answer he was ignorant of my other
faults else he would have mentioned
these alone
the more we value things outside our
control
the less control we have
he who laughs at himself never runs out
of things to laugh at
nature have given men one tongue but two
ears
that we may hear from others twice as
much as we speak
if you find yourself acting to impress
others or avoiding action out of fear of
what they might think
you have left the path
man is not worried by real problems so
much as his imagined anxieties about
real problems
wealth consists not in having great
possessions
but in having few once
circumstances don't make the man
they only reveal him to himself
it's better to live with one person of
high soul
and to be calm and independent than to
lead a miserable life in the Society of
many
suffering arises from trying to control
what is uncontrollable
or from neglecting what is within our
power
no man is free who is not a master of
himself
there is only one way to happiness and
that is to cease worrying about things
which are beyond our power or our will
just because someone's single doesn't
mean they're lonely
just like when someone's in a crowd
doesn't mean they're not alone
it's not what happens to you
but how you react to it that matters
if you want to improve
be content to be thought foolish and
stupid
the key is to keep company only with
people who uplift you
whose presence calls forth your best
the fools are cured of grief by time
the clever by their mind
freedom is the only worthy goal in life
it is one by disregarding things that
lie beyond our control
other people's views and troubles can be
contagious
don't sabotage yourself by unwittingly
adopting negative unproductive attitudes
through your associations with others
you are a little soul
carrying around a corpse
he who is not happy with little will
never be happy with much
first learn the meaning of what you say
and then speak
no
first Who You Are
and then Adorn yourself accordingly
attach yourself to what is spiritually
Superior regardless of what other people
think or do
hold to your true aspirations no matter
what is going on around you
any person capable of angering you
becomes your master
he can anger you only when you permit
yourself to be disturbed by him
if he will be said of thee and if it be
true correct thyself
if it be a lie
laugh at it
small-minded people blame others
average people blame themselves
the why see all blame as foolishness
don't seek to have events happen as you
wish
but wish them to happen as they do
happen
and all will be well with you
no matter what happens it is within my
power to turn it to my advantage
who is the rich man
he who is content
it is our attitude towards events not
events themselves which we can control
nothing is by its own nature calamitous
even death is terrible only if we fear
it
give me by all means the shorter and
nobler life
instead of one that is longer but of
less account
no great thing is created suddenly
any more than a bunch of grapes or a fig
if you tell me that you desire a fig
I answer that there must be time
let it first blossom
then bear fruit then ripen
it is unrealistic to expect people to
see you as you see yourself
foreign
not by the fulfilling of men's desires
but by the removal of Desire
difficulty shows what men are
we must not believe the many
who say that only free people ought to
be educated
but we should rather believe the
philosophers who say that only the
educated are free
is freedom anything other than the right
to live as we wish
nothing else
whenever someone helps or hinders you
or Praises or criticizes you remember
that they see you only through the lens
of their own impressions
if they act or speak from a warped
perspective they hurt themselves
not you
and banquets remember that you entertain
two guests
Body and Soul
and whatever you shall have given to the
body you soon eject
but what you shall have given to the
soul
you keep always
be careful with who you communicate with
people tend to imitate habits
those with whom we interact we
inadvertently adopt their interests
their opinions their values
and their habits interpret events
it's not a Pity that a person was born
or died
that he lost his money at home
all this property does not belong to him
but it's a Pity if a person loses his
true property or his dignity
good luck frees many men from punishment
but no man from Fear
a smart person fights passion
but a fool becomes its slave
do not try to seem wise to others
if you want to live a wise life
live it on your own terms and in your
own eyes
the essence of philosophy is that a man
should so live that his happiness shall
depend as little as possible on external
things
people shouldn't have many friends
because you'll get tired of getting
knives out of your back
a ship should not ride on a single
anchor
nor life on a single hope
foreign you become what you give your
attention to
to ascend the sun there is no need for
prayer no need for incantation no
it suddenly begins to send its raise for
the joy of all
so do not expect nor Applause nor noise
nor praise to do good
do good deeds voluntarily
and be loved like the sun
people are happy to find an excuse for
their transgressions
while philosophy teaches not to stretch
without thinking
even a finger
what you don't desire for yourself don't
desire others
you don't like to be a Slave
don't make others a Slave
Envy is the enemy of the happy